now this is normally the part in the
show where I would say hey if you shop
on Amazon you can support us with the
shopping that you do but unfortunately
Amazon has shut down they have shut the
whole thing down our Amazon affiliate
link which used to send us a little kick
back of somewhere between four and eight
percent of your purchases this is not
good and if you've been following 20:17
for the David Pakman show you know that
starting in late March early April we
became faced with by no choice of our
own YouTube D monetization there has
been a huge calamity on YouTube which
reduced in the short term our YouTube
revenue by 99% and it has now stabilized
down about 85% and that was just
absolutely crushing to us and as a
result I came to you and I said we've
got to make up that money and we started
clawing our way back up with new members
and patreon and and a couple of new
advertisers and we've recovered about 60
or 65% of that lost revenue and I was
hopeful that we were on our way to
recovering all of it maybe by the end of
the year maybe by the first quarter of
2018 and yesterday I was notified of the
unappealable definitive and final
decision that our amazon link has been
completely and totally shut down and
that was somewhere between 8 and 10
percent of our revenue of course after
we had the YouTube ad pocalypse and that
almost disappeared the 8 to 10 percent
that the Amazon affiliate revenue used
to represent represent increased just in
comparison and it's gone and a number of
programs and YouTube channels and
podcasts have dealt with this because of
Amazon cracking down they used to allow
shows like ours or at least we're
indifferent to shows like ours saying
hey bookmark our link and use it
whenever you shop but that is by the
letter of the Terms of Service something
that they can ban you for or cancel your
account for at any time and indeed our
account has been cancelled so this is
it's it's been the best year for the
David Pakman show in a lot of ways and
it's also been a disastrous year for the
David Pakman show in a lot of ways
because it has been one hit after
another so as a proud
ethical matter if you've been using that
link that link is dead
we have resupply linked the new
affiliate account to david pakman.com
slash amazon so you can the only if you
want to use this there's only one way to
do it which is eat don't bookmark
anything each time you shop just go to
david pakman.com slash amazon and we may
be blocked again from it i don't know
but the truth is we've been doing this
for seven years so there were hundreds
if not thousands of people in our
audience who had that link bookmarked
and we're using it whenever they shopped
so i'm anticipating that we will earn
you know one or two percent of what we
used to through amazon so if you were
using that link i'm asking you
consider replacing that contribution
with a dollar or two through patreon
okay it's really easy you go to
patreon.com/scishow
we've got one thousand nine hundred and
seventy-five people currently doing this
i want to get to twenty-five hundred and
i've mentioned before that when we get
to twenty five hundred patreon
contributors we will film and produce
and upload to youtube my 75 minute
long-form lectures from the class I've
been teaching at Boston College so
that's something upcoming but in the
short term we just we need your help to
replace the lost Amazon revenue and it
has really not been you know the show is
bigger than ever in terms of the
audience size but the monetizing of that
larger than ever audience is actually
quite low as a result of D monetization
and as a result of having lost the
Amazon revenue at this point so this is
really really bad please consider making
a contribution on patreon so that the
program can continue with all of our
plans for content and distribution you
can also look at membership you can if
if patreon is something you're already
doing you can also go to david
pakman.com slash membership and get a
membership there if you are not yet
doing patreon and you want to do
membership instead by all means check
that out and if you want a discount
right i don't need everybody to pay full
price we're trying to just get a couple
bucks from as many people in our
audience as possible to rebuild the
revenue you can use the coupon code
I voted 17 in the coupon code field and
that'll save you 40 percent so not a
good good situation for the David Pakman
show and I'll talk more about this other
part tomorrow we
now can accept contributions through
cryptocurrency Bitcoin aetherium and
litecoin okay we are going to set up a
page on the website with our addresses
for Bitcoin aetherium and litecoin but
effective immediately starting with
today's clips if you look at the video
description for all david pakman show
videos you will see listed our addresses
for Bitcoin aetherium and litecoin so if
there are those folks in our audience
who struck it big they got in early with
Bitcoin and they've got all these
bitcoins available now and a lot of
people have said David you should really
accept cryptocurrency we are now doing
it you can check that out in the video
description to all YouTube videos
starting today and I'll set up a page on
our website as well for that so please
please please do what you can and of
course we have we have a new Amazon
account it's david pakman.com slash
amazon don't bookmark it use it and
that's it maybe we can recover a little
bit of them of the lost money they're a
sad day for the day yesterday wasn't
just a bad day for the Trump
administration it was not a good day for
the David Pakman show either